as you probably already know apple just
had their annual september event
where they released their new apple
watch series 6 and they did something
this year that they usually don't do
they released a budget apple watch se
model
alongside the premium series 6. and to
make choosing a new watch even more
difficult
they're continuing to sell the series 3
model
which is now on sale on amazon for only
169
making it 110 less expensive than the
apple watch se
and 230 less expensive than the series
six
the point that i'm making is that it's
probably never been more tough
for new apple watch buyers to choose the
right model
for your needs and your budget or
potentially for your child
thanks to the new family setup feature
which i'll get into in just a minute so
what i'm gonna do in this video is
explain
every single difference between those
three apple watch models
and then i'm gonna recommend one for
each different use case
doing my best to make sure that you
don't make any purchasing mistakes
so before we jump in be sure to check
out our premium
apple product hoodie down below to keep
you nice and warm and cozy
as these final days of summer are slowly
fading away
oh and by the way thank you guys for
getting our video from yesterday on
youtube's trending page
definitely check out that video if you
already have an apple watch
and you're thinking of upgrading to the
series 6. now getting back to the
difference between the three apple watch
models
the biggest visible change is the
available finishes
the series 3 just gets silver or space
great aluminum
while the se adds gold aluminum but the
series 6 goes
all out adding two brand new aluminum
finishes
blue and product red on top of that you
can choose
unique stainless steel or titanium
finishes
but those models are priced much higher
than the others
the se and series 6 also come with a
case that's 11 percent
thinner than the one on the series 3. so
it helps them feel a little bit more
premium but by far
the most important feature that i think
holds the most value
is the fact that the series 3 uses the
smaller legacy display
that is squared off while the other two
have larger displays
with rounded corners which feel much
more modern and make it easier to read
what's on the display another
interesting point is that while the
series 3 supports some of the new watch
faces
it's limited to a smaller version like
the fire
watch face and there are a lot of new
watch faces that are
only available on the series 4 or newer
apple watch models
another difference is found on the back
with the ceramic and sapphire crystal
back on the series 6
and se instead of a composite back for
the series 3
and as you can see the new back looks
much more modern
that's also because the new watches come
with the 2nd gen optical heart sensor
a better accelerometer that can measure
up to 32 g
which allows it to enable the fall
detection feature
which can automatically notify a
designated contact
or the authorities if it detects a fall
and no further movement
the new sc and series 6 also get a
built-in compass
and always on altimeter a speaker that's
50
louder haptic feedback built into the
digital crown
32 gigabytes of storage instead of only
8 gigabytes on the series 3
and a better microphone which enables
the noise monitoring feature
in terms of spec differences they both
get ltpo displays
which are more efficient they both get
apple's updated w3 wireless chip
which is also more efficient they both
get bluetooth 5
and perhaps the biggest deal is the fact
that the series 3
cannot be configured with lce cellular
service
so it has to be in range of your iphone
or using wi-fi
this means that the series 3 doesn't get
international emergency calling
but it does support emergency sos only
if your iphone is nearby
the series 6 and sc can do this by
themselves
if you buy an lce model and because of
that you can use
family setup which means that you can
set up an apple watch
without requiring an iphone which is
perfect for kids
in terms of performance the series 3
comes with the s3
chip the se gets the s5 chip and the
series 6
gets the s6 chip we personally found the
s3 chip to be a little bit too slow
with the s5 being perfectly smooth so
we're not sure if the brand new s6 chip
in the series 6
is gonna make that big of a difference
in the real world surprisingly
all three of these models have the same
50 meters of water resistance
they can all notify you of any heart
rate discrepancies
and they all have the same 18 hours of
rated battery life
as far as the bands they all support the
same ones even the brand new solo loop
but since the case on the series 3 is
slightly smaller
you should probably order a slightly
larger band to account for the
difference
now before we finally get into our apple
watch buyer's guide
there are a couple of features that are
exclusive to the series 6
that i want to mention it of course gets
the always on display
which stays dimly lit instead of simply
shutting off when it's in standby mode
and it's now two and a half times
brighter than on the series 5
when in always on mode it also gets the
exclusive ecg test feature
and the brand new blood oxygen
measurement feature
which can be a huge deal for people with
health issues
on top of that it's the very first apple
watch to support the 5 gigahertz band
wi-fi connection
and it's the first to get apple's new
ultra wideband chip
which could enable some really cool
features down the road so there you guys
go
there are all the differences between
those apple watch models
and with that let's get into the buyer's
guide if you're someone who really cares
about the fashion aspect of owning an
apple watch
and you don't really have a limited
budget then the series 6 is probably the
best choice for you
because it comes in the largest variety
of finishes so you can for example
get a gold stainless steel case and a
matching chain link
band which looks very premium on top of
that the series 6 supports the always-on
display
making it look more like a real watch
when you're not using it
and of course it comes with the best
specs and all the new unique features
like ecg
blood oxygen monitoring and the u1 chip
but i'd say that if those features don't
really matter much to you
and you're looking for the best bang for
your buck then the apple watch se
is probably the best choice because it
packs the same design
and almost all of the same features as
the series 6.
the most important one is the larger
display with rounded corners
which makes the biggest difference for
day-to-day use
the s5 chip isn't as fast but in our
experience
it performs very well and doesn't limit
you
in any way like the series 3's s3 chip
does
it also gets the same 2nd gen sensors 32
gigs of storage
and improvements like the better speaker
and microphone
now if you simply just want a basic
apple watch
for the absolute best price especially
if you just want it to track your heart
rate
and other metrics for fitness and
workouts
you really can't beat the 169 dollar
sale on amazon
which we have links to down in the
description below you can still use all
the same bands
but you're limited to the silver and
space gray aluminum finishes
you don't get the full selection of
watch faces but you probably don't mind
if you're going with that model you
don't get the best specs
like for example bluetooth 4.2 the older
w2 chip and
just 8 gigs of storage but that probably
doesn't matter that much to you
if you just need a simple apple watch
for a great price
however there is one major mistake you
need to avoid
if you're considering the apple watch
series 3. if you're thinking of getting
it as a gift for an elderly person
or if you're buying it for your child to
take advantage of the new family setup
feature
the series 3 is not going to cut it
because it doesn't support
lte cellular service so they'll have to
have an iphone
to set it up this new feature is
absolutely great
if your child is not quite old enough to
have their own cell phone
but you still want to keep track of
their location and be able to call them
at any time knowing that they can pick
up your phone call
right from their wrist and for that the
new cellular model of the apple watch sc
is the absolute best bang for your buck
starting at 329
since service providers charge
significantly less per month
to connect a smart watch compared to a
dedicated smartphone line
and your kids will also get the added
benefit of all the fitness features
which can help encourage them to
exercise but if your child or an
elderly person has certain health issues
it may be a good idea to get the series
6 model
to take advantage of the blood oxygen
monitoring and
ecg testing features but that does bring
the price up to 500
instead of 329 for the apple watch sc
so with all that said if this video
helped you make a purchasing decision
you can find links to each of those
watches down in the description below
but if you're still unsure you can
comment your specific situation
down below and we'll help you out and
you can wait for our full hands-on
comparison between those watches
coming very soon so be sure to click the
circle above to subscribe
so you don't miss out on that and
definitely check out our new apple
product mask
down below thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video